ingredient just recently revealed their
new 20 series cheap use but there are
quite a bit more costlier than what the
10 series launched for so why is this
[Music]
welcome to Haris hobbies so first of all
nvidia is trying to make the 20 series
of premium lineup and make great
Racing's seem like something that's very
unique people often associate high
quality premium items with high prices
and same thing works backwards if
something is highly priced people think
that has a lot of quality and it is
really premium so for the average person
who walks into Best Buy and hasn't done
that much research Lopes to the 20
series and things that it is something
luxurious and posh many of these people
assume is a 20 series is really good
because only people who are willing to
spend a lot of money can afford it as a
result to them it may seem like the 20
series is actually worth having so
overall by pricing the 20 series higher
nvidia is trying to convince the average
consumer that ray-tracing technology and
a 20 series is something really premium
and that it is reserved for enthusiasts
secondly nvidia is almost certainly
implementing an extra fee or early
adopters fee which will most likely go
away after single year they know that
over 90% of the people buying a new GPU
within one year of its release are some
buying that card and will fire
regardless of its price many of these
people are really just interested in
having the best newest thing available
and not really about to value that if
they get out of their product and as a
result Nvidia really takes advantage of
these people and tries to profit more on
them thirdly NVIDIA has absolutely no
competition they barely even had a
competition for the high level ten
series cards so they actually have no
competition for the high level 20 series
cards and have a really strong monopoly
so whether you're genuinely need or want
that performance whether it's for simple
gaming or whether it's crucial for your
animating business either way you would
have to go in Nvidia or not buy GPU at
all they are the only option in that
performance range so they can really
just get away with whatever price that
they want to fourthly at this point many
people are really just desperate
I've been waiting for many many months
due to GP price inflation which is still
really bad outside of the US and they're
really just sick of waiting and they're
okay with spending around $100 or so to
just finally get a GPU many of them opt
out for buying the 10 series because it
was almost outdated and they wanted to
get the 23 years right when it launched
and now this 20 series has finally
launched they're just gonna go buy it
despite the price and finally many
people are suggesting that Nvidia launch
a 20 series for such a high price in
order to keep the 10 series relevant and
meaningful and I really do see where is
it coming from but I don't think there's
a correlation between a 20 series and
the 10 series inventory I truly believe
that Nvidia were launched for these
crisis regardless of how much 10 series
inventory they have laser is simply so
much hype surrounding a 20 series and
many people really just needed a cheap
you say media could easily get away with
high pricing and as we're discussing the
10 series make sure you don't forget
about the 10 series the 10 series is
really a solid set of cars that will
last for many many years in the future
and they are really well priced right
now especially the 1080 there are huge
discounts and great offers across the
board and price are still dropping too
so overall Nvidia is practicing their
twenty series really high because
they're trying to advertise the twenty
series as a really high premium product
targeted at people who want the best and
newest tech available and the people who
really just need a GPU and they can get
away with this because they have no
competition
mm invidious perspective since most
early buyers buy the GPU
regardless of price Nvidia sales volume
is not affected but their profits
dramatically increase but not just what
I think what do you guys think China is
a crucial point where the twenty series
is so high
make sure comment down below what you
guys think because I do read all my
comments and curious what you guys think
to make sure to post your thoughts also
if you guys like this video then make
sure drop a like and consider
subscribing if you'd like to see more
videos just like this one but until then
I'm hari
I'll see you guys on the next one
[Music]